the pigs now we can say our upcoming
film the pigs cometh is based on a true
story
feral pigs torment residents of New
Zealand Capital Wellington city council
says feral pig population in suburbs has
been expanding so that's just the gist
of the story the people who live in
Wellington New Zealand are apparently
what's going on Ian they're being
attacked by pigs yeah somebody lost like
40 goats or something to pigs in the
last month or so oh the pigs
quote it's a murder scene according to
this one witness wow so so we're
planning a movie called the pigs cometh
and the idea was it's like New York City
and there's like all they like it starts
with them being like hi the mayor hereby
Proclaim all guns are banned and then
everyone's like yay and then it shows
the cops like just like grabbing guns
and all the gangs are turning their guns
in and then everyone's like we've we've
done it the guns are gone and then all
of a sudden they see like a pig like in
the distance just like eating garbage
and they're like What's that they're
like it's just a pig don't worry and
then the Pig turns real quick and then
starts running full speed at the crowd
and they're like ah and then the whole
movie's like this horror film where
they're like what do we do how do we
stop the pigs I have no idea and the
pig's just rampaging and that was the
idea for the film we had and then before
the show Ian told me it's actually
happening so now we can say based on a
true story and wait did we did did the
New York City residents get rid of
knives and and uh axes and you you might
be a little no no no no no no no they
don't exist in this world are you joking
you think you're gonna fight 50 feral
Hogs with a knife good luck bro dude
apparently they're about they range up
to 260 pounds I mean they might be even
though all right dude yeah all right
let's let's see how you handle like a
whole heavyweight on all four that's a
great plot twice the the the 250 pound
boar is just like
and the guy goes I've got a steak knife
and then he gets mauled by the pig but
you've seen First Blood right Rambo yeah
the first the first Rambo movie no he's
in he's in the woods he's hungry and and
he he takes his knife
anybody can climb up a tree
and tie a knife to a stick and then jump
down perfectly uh and and uh kill a
board and then strip it and eat it
anybody can do that I think anybody can
technically uh just depends on if they
if they're if they actually yeah pigs
could be like 300 plus pounds New York
New Yorkers New Yorkers are very
resources look at this look at the story
from the guardian it's a murder scene
feral pigs torment residents in New
Zealand Capital don't they like heavily
regulate guns in New Zealand
marauding feral pigs have blighted
essential suburb in New Zealand's
Capital the subway Brooklyn it says
Brooklyn not New Zealand you're reading
that oh Brooklyn okay what I'm I'm
trying to make a joke oh it's just a
suburb of Brooklyn in New Zealand
a suburb of Wellington yeah
it's a suburb of Brooklyn I was just
making a joke oh did I read it I'm not
no I'm I'm making a joke you're fine I'm
sorry oh okay all right anyway the pig
night everybody look at this look at
this a boar killed in a ghost holy crap
so if a kid can kill a boar no no in
your scale yeah the kid's just happy
it's the kids the penny next to the uh
okay all right so so but in all
seriousness as they're banning guns
across the board the gag that I'm like
the joke I'm making is
it's not really a joke it's like you ban
weapons then what do you do when wild
animals show up because this is a thing
like these people in big cities are like
guns should be banned nobody needs more
than you know if you're a hunter and you
need more than 10 rounds Europe you had
Hunter and it's like oh okay so in like
four wild boars Rampage through your
property and they all weigh 200 pounds
tell me that 10 rounds is enough I feel
like the
Lake Simpson's episode where where
everybody collected all the guns and
then something happened where they
needed guns the Family Guy did it maybe
it was uh like a Halloween episode or
something but a Family Guy maybe the
chat can you know it knows what I'm
talking about it might be Family Guy but
Peter melts down all the plumbing to
make guns and then the townsfolk are
like it's a post-apocalyptic and they're
like you got rid of our plumbing for
guns and he goes that's right and then
they throw him and and his the Griffins
out of the city and then radioactive
Stewie babies and they go to the Twinkie
factory yeah so that was yeah okay that
was a Twinkie factory and the stewies
the tentacles go and attack everybody
and the guy's like quick grab the guns
and they're on finals I can't and then
Stewie kills them all there's another
episode where the guns were turned into
a statue celebrating non-violence and
then an invading Army came in and then
took over everyone and they couldn't uh
I forgot which which uh which is that
Simpsons I I think that could have been
the Simpsons people in the chat room
will let us know them thank you thank
you right now dude some people are
saying to look up Hogzilla uh someone
already probably even made that movie so
I was just looking this up and there is
a hypothetical one thousand pound hog
that they killed somewhere in the U.S
and I don't think that's or I think it
might have been in Russia and I don't
think it was ever proven but there's
like a picture they thought might have
been forced perspective this is North
Carolina golly yeah
there's one like in Turkey that's like a
dinosaur that's not a uh I want to see
you with your butter knife Andrew handle
that let's see what you could do there
that's a vicious murderous mammal like
that will kill a human kind kind of
thing it's like a bear but faster it's
dead so what happened no bears can go
like 35 miles bears are pretty nice but
it says Alabama boy bags wild hogs
regularly with 450 Bushmaster so you can
give a kid proper training and a
powerful enough rifle he can take down
that monster you take away the guns good
luck anyone that's the thing about guns
it's a great equalizer right well
whether you're a five foot tall woman or
a six foot seven pure lean muscle man if
you're going to get into a conflict that
gun normalizes the fight between them
well then you have all the larpers and
everything that have uh swords and so
swords still exist in your world right I
mean it's a good idea so like while the
pigs are rampaging around some
cosplayers jump out and they strike a
pose with their swords but their swords
are fake you know because it's like we
have some fake swords and we have some
real swords or those Minecraft uh sponge
swords you see it uh the foam swords
okay all right well you know we're we're
gonna I wanted an executive producer uh
here's the best part
the McGuffin is that someone finds a box
of bullets and they're like we have to
get this to the HQ where they have the
last gun and they have to like travel
across all of Manhattan with marauding
pigs everywhere and that's like the item
to like you have to get it and it's like
the ring and then they get it and then
they're like they get to the the guy's
house and he's like I was able to save
one rifle and it's like a it's like a
it's like a um
like a civil war right no no no no like
it's got to be like a standard like you
know something like an M1 it's got to be
able to just you know oh okay maybe
maybe it'll be like a bolt action 308 it
was like in a museum from World War yeah
there you go or something yes yeah and
then it's like you know it's a single
load bolt action or something but it's
all they got and then with that they're
able to stop the pigs one by one one
shot at a time I'm looking at stats on
Hogzilla apparently scientists Zoom the
corpse and they found it to be about 800
pounds uh between seven and eight and a
half feet long and uh it's it was a
hybrid between a wild boar and a
domestic Pig whoa and the tusks were
about two feet they were longer than two
feet each they're 28 inches each
so one was 28 inches one was 19 inches
so the different lengths of Tusk the
funny thing about this is that Meme
where the left was like we're gonna ban
guns and the guy was like what do I do
when you know 15 to 30 feral Hogs you
know attack my property or whatever and
then all the Liberals were like laughing
like you're so dumb hugs and everybody
who lives in the middle of nowhere was
like so what this like some quotes from
the person that's dealing with the hog
infestation said about they lost about
60 goats in the last few months and what
happens is if they quote if they find
something they like eating meaning the
Hogs and it's a free feed meaning a
newborn kid which is a baby goat they're
gonna keep coming back so it's just it's
just over and over and over again these
swarms of gigantic muscular beasts come
slaughtering uh yeah you need guns for
that
get big and they're dangerous that's it
period but people are so used to living
in luxury with security and bricks and
bridges and all of the wonders of the
modern world that they've not
experienced look you know where these
stories come from about monsters of
Legend we have these stories in like
ancient myth of giant beasts being
fought by Noble Heroes and it's like
this giant monster slang a dragon it's
because way back in the day some dude
was in a tribe of like 70 people and
he's like I'm going to go find berries
and there's walking through the forest
and he comes across some like 70 pound
pig and he's like oh it's a pig and then
he grabs a stick and he's whacking it
and the pig's biting at him and then he
cracks a second stabs it and wins then
he comes back goes I defeated a great
monster and he tells this story and then
everyone's imagining and they write it
down and the story passes down and then
eventually it's a gigantic 10 foot tall
you know Pig Beast you know what I mean
but we also always sit there eight feet
long on the heart if they stand up and I
mean if they're 800 pounds the giant
spiders I mean that that stuff probably
used to exist until Humanity
extinctified at all but it's but it's
like somebody's walking down the road
traveling to the to the city to trade
some beans or something and then he
fought a bear and it was like a
medium-sized bear and he barely survived
and he comes back and he's bleeding and
he's like I killed a giant Beast must
have been seven feet tall and then the
story is told nowadays
people don't go wander off in the woods
for the most part people still get
killed by like mountain lions and stuff
but the average person living in a city
has no idea how dangerous it is to be in
the middle of nowhere I'll tell you this
man we're by the Appalachian Trail go
out during a new moon and stand on that
trail and you will be freaked up out
well like coyotes the weird noises the
rustling the creatures that can see you
and you can't see them it's pitch black
yeah that's one of those no Jersey
things oh yeah you're ncu you're in the
woods so we went out uh last year during
a new moon
we're on our bikes and it's pitch black
on the Forest Trail and so we stopped
and turned the lights off and you hear
like things circling you you hear like
the rustling running around you and
you're like you know something
something's going on they're probably
scared of you who knows but you hear
weird noises weird like hooting and I'm
like I got no idea everything is Pitch
Black you turn the bikes on turn the
lights on and we just sped off it was
fun but it was freaky now imagine most
people live in a situation like that
would probably be in favor of guns which
is probably why we have 2A because back
then it is dangerous Pig could Rampage
to the town someone had to shoot it and
their guns weren't even that good these
days everybody lives in a city they're
they're in their concrete cubicle it
smells like sour milk and they never see
these pigs but the problem is wait so
what's the name of this movie the pigs
cometh Okay so
let me get it straight the the first
movie set in a city and then the pigs
cometh again
that's the one that's set in the woods
there's not what we can do you're doing
a sequel sure you're setting up the
sequel you know the the you know the the
animals
yeah they have to go find the source of
the pigs deep underground now all of
them yes all the urban Liberals are like
armed and muscular from fighting the
pigs and now they know and they're like
the only way we bring back peace is to
destroy the Hogs from The Source the
source of China but there's we gotta do
underground to get there the source is
Hogzilla it's like
yeah okay all right giant hog yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there